le 13 il n'a pas forcément tu es quelque
chose en moi me là
il a exacerbé les traits de caractère
les plus sûrs et plus louis pessimiste
c'est pour lui devenu simplement le xiii
2 tout petit mot pour nommer un massacre
qui allait redéfinir sa vie est blessé
toute une nation
le 13 novembre 2015 christophe naudin
assistait au concert des eagles of death
metal avec deux amis au bataclan
l'attentât terroriste a fait 131 morts
dont son ami vincent et plus de 400
blessés j'ai plus des des flashs par
épisode
le concert des des échanges que j'ai eus
avec vincent et david quand je vais
chercher des bières quand je votre
lettre m comme ça le moment de l'attaqué
que je raconte quand je suis voilà des
moments on va dire moins agréable quand
je suis dans la fosse que j'ai que j'ai
peur que l'on demande où je vais toucher
extra christophe naudin vient tout juste
de publier son journal de rescapés du
bataclan un livre qui témoigne d'une
colère qui remonte en lui avec chaque
attentat qui frappe la france depuis il
s'en prend autant à une droite qui
pensent vers l'islamophobie qu'à sa
propre famille politique de la gauche il
avait tendance pour moi même s'ils s'en
défendent à présenter elles étaient au
risque parfois comme d un peu d je
schématise mais c'est ça des victimes de
la société ce qui ne ferait pas pour
d'autres types de terroristes par
exemple les suprémacistes blancs et donc
je trouvais ça injuste voilà même
obscène parfois dans certaines
interventions son journal pose le regard
d'un chercheur qui veut comprendre sans
excuser experts de l'islam médiéval et
politique de formation
il dévore les publications jihadiste sur
lesquels il peut mettre la main ils
épluchent les réseaux sociaux je pense
que quand on est dans l'incompréhension
et dans la peur et dans la le rejet on
tourne en boucle
alors que la de comprendre ça fait enfin
personnellement tout cas ça me fait un
peu avancé même si j'ai pas tout les
tous les éléments jeu voilà en gros jeux
pour moi la religion en tout cas la
version évidemment radicale et
extrémiste ou ce qu'on veut intégriste
de la religion est centrale
ce n'est pas un vernis c'est pas un
prétexte pour moi
de tous les attentats terroristes
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit devant son
collège en octobre là particulièrement
remuer christophe naudin et lui aussi
professeur d'histoire et géographie des
genres 2015
il raconte sa peur que l'école et
l'enseignement laïc devienne la
prochaine cible des terroristes
ça m'a pas étonné ça va sidéré sur le
coup et évidemment avec la violence de
la façon qu'il ya qu'elle s'était faite
même si ça aussi c'est pas étonnant de
leurs pas une forme de rituel aussi donc
je m'y attendais mais j'ai quand même
pris en pleine figure et les professeurs
avaient pensé boudé le procès qui doit
se tenir au début de l'an prochain si la
situation sanitaire le permet mais il
s'est ravisé et s'est inscrit en tant
que partie civile
c'est important pour moi pour deux
choses le procès on le voit avec celui
des attentats de janvier 2015
ça donne une parole aux victimes qui est
une part ok c'est un peu différent des
paroles qu'on peut avoir quand on est
moins dans les médias ou dans des livres
etc et après plus personnellement c'est
aussi comprendre comment ça s'est passé
on en revient toujours à la
compréhension
d'où ça vient c'est à dire qui a
commandité on a l'impression que chez
christophe naudin c'est l'historien
qu'il emporte chaque fois sur la victime
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada